right now some breaking news at the
border despite
biden's denials of a crisis brewing
the new york times is reporting just
moments ago that the number of
unaccompanied migrant children detained
along the southern border
has tripled in the last two weeks alone
to more than 3250
more than 1360 of the children have been
detained beyond the 72 hours
permitted by law before a child must be
transferred
to a shelter joining me now is senator
tom cotton
and i know he wants answers here senator
why is joe biden waiting until later
this week
for a briefing from his team on this
growing security health-related and
humanitarian crisis of his own making
hey laura it's good to be on with you
and that's a great question because we
have a crisis at the border
this is the biden border crisis now joe
biden and the democrats
may not think it's a border crisis
because they don't believe in borders so
they by definition don't think there can
be a crisis at the border but the
american people know
that we have a crisis there and this was
all together predictable in fact
predicted
i said last year during the campaign you
cannot promise amnesty
and open borders and health care for
illegal aliens
and not expect a migrant crisis at a
border and what's happened not just in
the last few weeks but every month since
the election
we've seen increased numbers at our
southern border and they sent a team
down
this week to ask about whether or not
there were enough teachers there
or what the accommodations were for kids
how about the team ask
what are we doing to stop it and to turn
these migrants back and to tell them
this is not the way to come to america
senator
the press secretary for president biden
today
said that they have to basically be
better with their messaging
on this is this a messaging problem when
you have a hundred and what 80 kids 30
kids
who are under the age of 13 some of whom
are kept
in these cement cells that they were
getting on trump for having to
keep people in temporarily until he
basically solved the border problem
no laura when a politician tells you
that messaging or communications problem
what they really mean is they have a
reality problem
and their reality problem is that they
created a crisis at our southern border
by inviting the entire world to show up
and claim
asylum look donald trump turned away
people who were seeking asylum and told
them to stay in mexico
and that their claims could be
adjudicated in an orderly fashion from
mexico
joe biden's administration is seeking
out those illegal aliens that donald
trump turned away
and inviting them to come back to the
border enter like we've gone far beyond
catch and release
this is recruiting release they're
specifically recruiting illegal aliens
who already turned away once to come
back so they can be let go into the
country
all of almost all of these claims will
be rejected the simple fact is
if you're from central america and
you're seeking asylum
you do that at the southern border of
mexico when you get all the way to the
southern border of the united states
you're no longer seeking asylum
you're seeking a better job and better
living conditions yeah remember
they were sent out of the united states
immediately during covet because
we're not supposed to be bringing people
into the country who are potential
covetous but
that was suspended and done away with by
president biden all right senator